(Año 1955, Corea del Sur es un país corrupto,
inestable y muy dependiente de la ayuda exterior.
Devastado por la guerra, Corea del Sur se
sitúa en ese momento como el tercer país
más pobre de Asia.
Su renta per cápita era equivalente a la
de países africanos como Ghana, soportaba
la mayor inflación de todo el continente
y la menor tasa de crecimiento.
Gobernado a partir de 1961 con mano de hierro por el autoritario General Park Chung-he , las expectativas
para este país no eran nada pero que nada
buenas. Corea del Sur era un país de emigrantes
e incluso su vecino del norte parecía un
país más prometedor.)
Pero, un momento, amigos porque esta no es
la historia que todos conocemos.
Corea del Sur es hoy el país del K-pop,el
K-beauty, el K-fashion y los K-dramas
[Y también del Kimchi, esa cosa roja que
parece que los coreanos comen a todas horas
y que a mí personalmente, me encanta]
En definitiva, hablamos de un país que está
moda.
Amigos, la ola coreana, también conocida
como el Hallyu llega a prácticamente
todos los rincones del planeta.
Ahora bien, no penséis que se trata solo
de una cuestión cultural, en absoluto. Las
empresas surcoreanas como Samsung, Hyunday
o LG también extienden sus tentáculos por
los 5 continentes.
(Y no es para menos. Este país, Corea del
Sur ha sido protagonista una de las mayores
historias de éxito económico de todos los
tiempos.
En poco más de 3 décadas, en apenas una
generación, Corea del Sur pasó de ser un
país del tercer mundo a convertirse en uno
de los países más ricos y prósperos de
la tierra.)
Y la pregunta es, ¿cómo consiguió Corea
del Sur todo este desarrollo, cómo logró
convertirse un país tan rico?
[Pues.. No, está hoy no es la pregunta, porque
esto ya os lo contamos en un pasado vídeo
que os dejo en la descripción]
El caso es que gracias al particular modelo
de desarrollo surcoreano caracterizado por
grandes grupos industriales - los chaebols
- por un sistema educativo muy exigente, una
enorme apertura al mundo, una gran acumulación
de capital y políticas activas de absorción
tecnológica, se produjo el conocido como
milagro económico surcoreano.
Pero,amigos... Lo que nos ha traído hasta
este vídeo es que hoy todo este modelo parece
agotado.
En 2017 ganó las elecciones este hombre,
el actual presidente, Moon Jae-in con una
promesa: apostar por nuevas políticas que
dieran un vuelco al modelo económico de Corea
del Sur.
Y, ojo porque no estamos hablando de políticas
nada pero que nada convencionales. Atentos.
¿UN MODELO AGOTADO?
Sí, Corea del Sur es hoy uno de los países
más ricos del planeta y…. sigue creciendo,
pero su modelo tiene problema y muchos indicadores
presentan una tendencia negativa.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, se espera que en 2019
el país registre el menor crecimiento de
los últimos 7 ejercicios; su tasa de desempleo
tuvo en enero su peor registro en 9 años,
los salarios no crecen y los jóvenes cada
vez tienen más problemas para encontrar un
empleo.
[Algo nada frecuente en la Corea del Sur de
los últimos 30 años.]
“Desafortunadamente, ya que nosotros mismos
no vemos el futuro de Corea con bastante optimismo,
no quiero traer niños a esta sociedad poco
prometedora. Creo que esta forma de pensar
es compartida entre muchos de mis colegas.
[Bueno, supongo que os parecen motivos suficientes
como para preocuparse, ¿verdad? Pues… esperad
porque aún hay más.]
Los hogares, las familias de Corea del Sur
acumulan deudas equivalentes a casi el 100%
del Producto interior Bruto, lo que les convierte
en los hogares más apalancados de todos los
países del mundo.
Y es que, veréis, sí, ... los surcoreanos
ahorran mucho pero también invierten mucho,
especialmente en viviendas.
Y luego encima, por otro lado, la mayoría
de los empleos son tan poco productivos que
las jornadas laborales se extienden una barbaridad.
Y cuando digo barbaridad pero refiero a una
barbaridad con todas sus letras. Fijaos:
“ Corea del Sur termina con la inhumanamente
larga jornada de 68 horas semanales. El presidente
introduce una semana de trabajo de 52 horas
para ayudar a mejorar la calidad de vida e
impulsar la natalidad.
“Si no trabajo horas extras, mi salario
se reduce. Preferiría trabajar más para
cobrar más.)
[Vamos, que tal y como véis la sensación
de agotamiento del modelo es muy intensa[
Y ojo porque estamos hablando tan solo la
punta del iceberg.
Veréis la economía surcoreana tiene algunas
características muy a tener en cuenta.
(Por un lado la economía de Corea del Sur
está dividida por así decirlo en dos grandes
partes:
Los enormes Chaebols que tienen una importancia
enorme. Tan solo los 10 mayores grupos del
país representan más del 40% del PIB (44,2%
en 2018)
Estos grupos, reciben favores y privilegios
del gobierno, controlan entidades financieras
y tienen comportamientos que persiguen limitar
la competencia dentro del país)
Luego, por otro lado están las PYMEs, las
pequeñas y medianas empresas. Más de 3,5
millones de empresas que no tienen privilegios
y que están sujetas el enorme poder de los
chaebols. Algo que tiene importantísimas
consecuencias.
Por ejemplo los salarios promedios de las
PYMEs, que es donde trabajan la mayoría de
surcoreanos, son aproximadamente la mitad,
la mitad que los salarios en las grandes empresas
y la brecha no para de crecer.
¿Por qué? Pues, entre otras cosas porque
los grandes chaebols se comportan de forma
monopolística y hay muchas sospechas de colusión
entre estos grupos y muchos políticos.
Es decir, que los directivos de un grupo se
ponen de acuerdo con los directivos de otro
grupo y también con los políticos para limitar
la competencia y repartirse el mercado.
Ante esa situación su poder sobre las PYMES
es enorme… si no aceptas sus condiciones
simplemente tienes que cerrar.
Y no se trata de que exista sólo una diferencia
salarial, durante los últimos años el número
de PYMES que se declaran en bancarrota no
deja de crecer.
(Por si todo esto fuera poco, el desarrollo
tecnológico de países como China está incrementando
la competencia y la presión sobre la economía
surcoreana que es muy, pero que muy dependiente
de las exportaciones. Exageradamente dependiente
de las exportaciones.)
Pues bien, esto está haciendo que los chaebols
trasladen parte de su producción a otros
países y que sustituyan a proveedores locales
por proveedores extranjeros.
“Las compañías coreanas no pueden competir
con China e India en precio y deberían ascender
en la cadena de valor. Pero la evolución
industrial hacia productos de alto valor añadido
no está teniendo lugar en el sector de las
pequeñas y medianas empresas por su dependencia
con los conglomerados” - Park Sang-in, profesor
de economía en la Universidad Nacional de
Seúl )
Es algo que está pasando sin ir más lejos
que con la industria del automóvil.
(Corea del Sur es uno de los mayores fabricantes
de automóviles del mundo. Pues bien, a pesar
del buen momento que se ha vivido en el sector
durante los últimos años, la producción
surcoreana lleva 3 años consecutivos cayendo.
¿Por que? Pues porque Hyundai que controla
el 70% del mercado nacional está trasladando
producción y proveedores a países como México
e India.)
Al final, amigos, los privilegios que el gobierno
ha dado a estas grupos y las acciones que
estos han tomado para limitar la competencia
han hecho que la mayor parte de los empleos
estén ligados a compañías poco productivas,
con poca eficiencia y poca inversión en investigación
e innovación.
Y claro, si no tienes esas cosas pues no puedes
competir con países como China o Vietnam,
que tienen costes laborales mucho más pequeños.
Y esto es algo que está generando mucho miedo
en Corea del Sur.
Pero… precisamente, Moon Jae-in, el presidente,
ganó las elecciones de 2017 prometiendo resolver
todos estos problemas.
Y, ¿Sabéis que? Tiene un plan poco convencional.
¿Cómo quiere Moon Jae-in rescatar a Corea
del Sur? Bien, veámoslo.
(EL PLAN DEL PRESIDENTE MOON-JAE IN)
Queridos amigos de VisualPoltik, Moon Jae-in
ha prometido cambiar el modelo económico
de Corea del Sur de arriba abajo.
Y no penséis que quiere hacerlo con las recetas
típicas de menos impuestos o menos regulación.
Todo lo contrario.
El plan del presidente surcoreano se sustenta
en dos pilares.
El primero de ellos consiste en lo que sus
partidarios denominan la “democratizar la
economía”, que en la práctica consiste
en elevar los impuestos, incrementar el gasto
público, el empleo público y el salario
mínimo.
El cóctel completo.
Y no, precisamente en pequeñas cantidades.
Mirad:
(En 2019 el gasto público crecerá más de
un 10%, el mayor incremento en una década.
Por su parte, el salario mínimo creció un
16,4% en 2018 y en 2019 subirá un 10,9% adicional.
Y el gobierno ya ha dicho que ahí no se van
a terminar las subidas ni muchísimo menos.
Asimismo para financiar más gasto público
y la contratación de 850.000 nuevos empleados
públicos, Moon Jae-in ha impulsado la subida
dell impuesto sobre los beneficios de las
empresas que va a pasar del 22 al 25%, y también
se va a subir el impuesto sobre los salarios
más altos.)
La idea que tiene el gobierno es que todas
estas medidas eleven los ingresos de las familias
y con ello su consumo. Lo que reduciría la
dependencia que las empresas surcoreanas tienen
de las exportaciones.
¿El problema? Pues amigos… Que no está
funcionando.
Veréis, desde que Moon Jae-in ha empezado
a tomar estas medidas, la economía se está
desacelerando, el desempleo ha comenzado a
crecer y para colmo los ingresos de las familias
con menores ingresos no sólo no están subiendo
sino que están cayendo.
Sí, habéis escuchado bien. Sus salarios
suben pero muchos trabajadores han perdido
su empleo, de tal forma que el resultado neto
es que el 20% de las familias con menos recursos
ingresan menos dinero hoy que antes de la
subida de los salarios mínimos.
Todo esto explica que el índice de aprobación
del presidente haya pasado del 84% a mediados
de 2017 al 45% a día de hoy.
Pero… amigos, antes de terminar nos queda
ver el otro gran pilar en la estrategia del
presidente surcoreano. Atentos.
(MIRANDO AL NORTE)
Amigos, el Presidente surcoreano está convencido
de que el futuro de su país pasa por Corea
del Norte.
“Estamos en la línea de salida histórica
hacia una prosperidad común en la península
de Corea y en el noreste asiático. Esta es
una oportunidad que ha surgido como un milagro.
Es una oportunidad que nunca deberíamos perder.
Moon Jae-in)
¿Veis este mapa? En el podéis ver los planes
que Moon Jae-in tiene para Corea del Norte.
Quiere impulsar tres grandes cinturones económicos
que conecten el corazón industrial de Corea
del Sur con Corea del Norte, con China y con
Rusia, mediante nuevas líneas de ferrocarril,
carreteras, gasoductos, redes eléctricas,
etcétera, etcétera.
Tan solo las inversiones que se estima son
necesarias para impulsar los nuevos trenes
supondrían más de 40 mil millones de dólares.
Amigos, con todos estos proyectos el presidente
quiere mejorar las capacidades comerciales
de la economía surcoreana al tiempo que le
da a sus empresas acceso a los recursos y
a la mano de obra de Corea del Norte.
[Veréis, se calcula que el salario mensual
de un trabajador norcoreano podría estar
entorno a los 60$, que es mucho menos que
lo que cobran los trabajadores chinos o vietnamitas]
“Para Samsung Electronics, Corea del Norte
es un buen candidato en el que establecer
líneas de producción porque puede ofrecer
mano de obra barata, no tiene barrera lingüística
y tiene la misma zona horaria” -min,
(Por un lado, las negociaciones entre Corea
del Norte y Estados Unidos van despacio, por
otro lado las empresas surcoreanas no ven
muy claro que puedan invertir miles de millones
de dólares en Corea del Norte a corto plazo,
entre otras cosas porque no se fían del régimen
de Kim Jong-Un.)
Y luego está la última pregunta, ¿Quién
va a pagar todo ese enorme gasto que se va
a necesitar para llevar a cabo los planes
del presidente?
En fin, esta es la receta con la que Moon
Jae-in quiere transformar el modelo económico
surcoreano:
Más impuestos, más gasto público, más
empleo público, salarios mínimos más altos
y Corea del Norte.
¿Pensais que funcionará?.